par berger cette réforme était voulue
comme une grande réforme est ce que
finalement la montagne a accouché d'une
souris
non je pense que c'était pas une souris
d'arriver à avoir un rééquilibrage des
pouvoirs parce que ça n'a pas été dit
mais moi je suis très attaché c'est la
capacité pour le parlement d'avoir des
outils d'évaluation propre si on veut
assumer nos moyens d'évaluation et de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
il faut qu'on ait des outils propres ce
sera le cas et puis c'est pas non plus
une souris pour reprendre votre
expression d' introduire la
proportionnelle de limiter le nombre de
mandats dans le temps
je pense que ce sont des réformes qui
sont attendues par les français outre le
fait qu'elles ont été annoncé pendant la
campagne présidentielle
puis par président de la république
quand il nous avait réunis en congrès à
versailles ce sont des réformes qui sont
à penser qu'elles rejoignent pour la
durée l'essentiel n'ont pas d'autres
priorités
il ya toujours d'autres priorités mais
je pense que le mouvement de
renouvellement
on a réussi à insuffler lors de
l'élection présidentielle puis des
élections législatives ça doit pas être
juste une fois ça doit pas être juste ce
mandat là il faut que ça puisse inscrire
dans le temps et pour que ça s'inscrive
dans le temps il faut un moment changer
les règles de fonctionnement y compris
notre constitution notamment sur la
question de la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires
la question de la proportionnelle et la
question du non-cumul mais en quoi les
français seront mieux représentés
finalement s'il ya moins de députés de
sénateurs
c'est moins de députés et de sénateurs
mais c'est aussi mieux de parlementaires
parce que l'idée de faire cette réforme
c'est de la faire à moyens constants ça
coûtera pas un euro aux français mais ça
permettra aux parlementaires de mieux
faire leur travail
on l'a souvent dit nous depuis qu'on est
arrivé parce que on découvre aussi de
l'intérieur le mode de fonctionnement de
cette institution et on voit la
faiblesse aussi du sénat et de
l'assemblée par rapport justement au
gouvernement à l'exécutif
parce que nous n'avons pas des moyens
propres pour pouvoir expertise et
évaluer ce sera la garantie justement
sur ces moyens elles n'ont pas été
abordés par el orfi alors il ya
plusieurs choses par exemple fait que la
cour des comptes puissent être raté
c'est beaucoup plus aujourd'hui au
parlement alors qu'aujourd'hui elle
conseille autant l'exécutif que le
parlement le fait qu'on est un outil
propre d'évaluation soit dédiée à
l'assemblée nationale on pense par
exemple à frans stratégie qui est un
outil qui existe des
là c'est toujours à zéro euro
supplémentaire pour les français mais
nous ça va changer la manière avec
laquelle on va pouvoir travailler et
puis aussi des parlementaires qui auront
plus de moyens pas pour eux mêmes et
pour leur équipe parlementaire qui
feront qu on aura aussi un contact avec
la population avec les élus locaux qui
sera d'autant renforcée